how do you know what's happening in your
world the amount of information just a
click away may be limitless but the time
and energy we have to absorb and
evaluate it is not all the information
in the world won't be very useful unless
you know how to read the news to your
grandparents parents or even older
siblings this idea would have sounded
strange only a few decades ago news was
broad-based your choices were limited to
a couple of general interest magazines
and newspapers of record and three or
four TV networks we're trusted
newscasters delivered the day's news at
the same reliable time every evening but
the problems with this system soon
became apparent as mass media spread
while it was known that authoritarian
countries controlled and censored
information a series of scandals showed
that democratic governments were also
misleading the public often with media
cooperation revelations of covert wars
secret assassinations and political
corruption undermined public faith in
official narratives presented by
mainstream sources this breakdown of
trust in media gatekeepers led to
alternative newspapers radio shows and
cable news competing with the major
outlets and covering events from various
perspectives
more recently the Internet has
multiplied the amount of information and
viewpoints with social media blogs and
online video turning every citizen into
a potential reporter but if everyone is
a reporter nobody is and different
sources may disagree not only on
opinions but on the facts themselves so
how do you get the truth or something
close one of the best ways is to get the
original news unfiltered by middlemen
instead of articles interpreting a
scientific study or a politician's
speech you can often find the actual
material and judge for yourself for
current events follow reporters on
social media during major events such as
the Arab Spring
or the Ukrainian protests newscasters
and bloggers have posted updates and
recordings from the midst of the chaos
though many of these later appear in
articles or broadcast
keep in mind that these polished
versions often combine the voice of the
person who is there with the input of
editors who weren't at the same time the
more chaotic the story the less you
should try to follow it in real time in
events like terrorist attacks and
natural disasters today's media attempts
continuous coverage even when no
reliable new information is available
sometimes leading to incorrect
information or false accusations of
innocent people it's easy to be anxious
in such events but try checking for the
latest information at several points in
the day rather than every few minutes
allowing time for complete details to
emerge and false reports to be refuted
while good journalism aims for
objectivity media bias is often
unavoidable when you can't get the
direct story read coverage in multiple
outlets which employ different reporters
and interview different experts tuning
into various sources and noting the
differences lets you put the pieces
together for a more complete picture
it's also crucial to separate fact from
opinion words like think likely or
probably mean that the outlet is being
careful or worse taking a guess and
watch out for reports that rely on
anonymous sources these could be people
who have little connection to the story
or have an interest in influencing
coverage their anonymity making them
unaccountable for the information they
provide finally and most importantly try
to verify news before spreading it while
social media has enabled the truth to
reach us faster it's also allowed rumors
to spread before they can be verified
and falsehoods to survive long after
they've been refuted so before you share
that unbelievable or outrageous news
item do a web search to find any
additional information or context you
might have missed and what others are
saying about it today we are more free
than ever from the old media gatekeepers
who used to control the flow of
information but with freedom comes
responsibility the responsibility to
curate our own experience and ensure
that this flow does not become a flood
leaving us less informed than before we
took the plunge
you